Їхні обличчя закриті балаклавами, на очах темні окуляри.
Тільки так їх можуть показати пресі.
Це українські танкісти, яких готують в Німеччині
воювати на "Леопардах" в Україні.
У вас є відчуття страху? - Жодного.
Звертатися можна було лише німецькою мовою і через перекладача.
Запитувати щось навіть українською не дозволяється.
Такі вимоги Бундесверу на полігоні у федеральній землі Саксонія-Ангальт,
що на сході Німеччини за дві години їзди від Берліна.
Керувати німецькими танками "Леопард 1" навчають
інструктори з Німеччини, Данії та Нідерландів.
Танки дуже добрі. Є в нього декілька значних переваг
над російськими танками Т-72.
З тих, що я можу назвати - це швидкість та маневровість "Леопардів"
і їхня точна гармата.
Інші не буду я називати, щоб не полегшувати роботу противнику.
Німецький уряд оголосив про рішення постачати Україні танки "Леопард"
ще понад пів року тому - на початку лютого.
У Німеччині пройшли навчання вже близько шести тисяч
українських військовослужбовців, а до кінця цього року їхня кількість
перевищить позначку 10 тисяч. Особливий акцент на танкістах.
Насправді це у нас вже перевірена програма для такого специфічного навчання.
Вони приходять сюди з нульовими знаннями про цю конкретну бойову машину,
незалежно від того, пройшли вони попередню підготовку
на іншому танку чи ні. Вони практично знайомляться
із цією машиною, з усіма її особливостями та функціями.
Насправді цей графік ми на цей момент не дуже змінили,
тому що він вже добре зарекомендував себе в минулому.
На початку перших етапів навчання ми проаналізували,
що добре, а що не дуже. На цей момент ми маємо перевірений спосіб
навчання і ви бачили, що вони тут засвоїли за короткий проміжок часу
і продемонстрували гідну стрільбу.
Українські ж танкісти небагатослівні.
Вони дякували німецькій владі за допомогу, уникали зайвих деталей
про особливості підготовки. Натомість жартували.
Я б краще в Німеччину приїхав просто на екскурсію,
на відпочинок, ніж на такі навчання.
Євген зі сходу України. Йому 32 роки. Вдома його чекає дружина
і 6-річний син. До війни він працював диспетчером електромереж,
а після початку повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну
перекваліфікувався на танкіста.
По-перше, є величезна мотивація.
Хочеться швидше перемогти.
А інше… Ми ж навчалися на своїх танках.
Танк є танк. Трішки відрізняється, але, я б сказав, що на "Леопарді"
навчатися навіть простіше, ніж на наших танках.
Інструктори відзначають високу мотивацію, з якою українці
освоюють німецьку техніку. Кажуть, що військові ЗСУ навчаються
значно швидше за європейців. Курс навчання розрахований на 6 тижнів,
заняття відбуваються шість днів на тиждень.
Я хотів би наголосити на тому, що ми бачимо насамперед:
це неймовірно виняткова мотивація, оперативна готовність
і жага українських солдатів до навчання.
Це насправді дуже надихає і мотивує військових інструкторів,
чи то німецьких, чи, як у цьому випадку, данських та голландських інструкторів.
Їх це надихає і вони намагаються дати за такий короткий час
якомога більше знань, необхідних для того, щоб упоратися
з цим жахливим випробуванням - необхідністю йти на війну.
Ці маневри зі стрільбою були завершенням навчання чергової групи
українських танкістів. З 17 цілей вони вразили 15.
Причому з першого разу. Наступного тижня вони повертаються в Україну.
І на їхнє місце приїжджають нові. Українські військові впевнені:
отримані в Німеччині навички допоможуть їм в контрнаступі.